oh je pense que tout le monde en connaît
au moins un ou une peut-être plusieurs
c'est la personne qui vous a coupé la
route ce matin en voiture c'est celle
qui vous à marcher sur les pieds sans
s'excuser dans les transports c'est
peut-être votre chef qui a refusé la
promotion que vous demander légitimement
ou peut-être un autre chef ou une chef
qui vous met la pression tous les jours
tout aussi inutilement et à un moment ou
à un autre vous avez pensé de lui ou
d'elle quelconque quelle conne
c'est ce problème là que je voudrais
affronter avec vous ce soir
[Musique]
je sais que vous souffrez et celui
peut-être qu'il ya allumer le chauffage
ce soir dans cette salle
et je sais que vous en souffrez dans mon
cas c'est quelqu'un qui m'a empêché
d'écrire un livre
j'étais en colocation cette colocation
s'est mal passé j'ai dû renoncer à
écrire le livre que je préparais et je
ne savait pas encore qu'il allait m'en
donner un autre nom inspiré un autre
dont je voudrais vous livrer aujourd'hui
les conclusions
ce que j'ai découvert lors de mon
enquête philosophique sur ce que c'est
que la connerie c'est d'abord que avant
d'être une qualité ou un défaut propres
à une personne
c'est l'objet d'un jugement qu une
personne aimée sur une autre personne
par exemple moi qui suis comme vous
l'imaginez un saint ou plus ou moins
dignes d'un ange
en tout cas c'est la position qui est
celle de la personne qui émet un
jugement
eh bien je prête cet attribut de
conneries à une autre personne c'est lui
ici je vous le représente entre
parenthèses puisque bien sûr ce qu'il
ressent ou ses motivations
en fait nous ne voulons rien en savoir
nous ne cherchons plus à comprendre
nous nous sommes dans le jugement c'est
à dire dans ce cas ci dans le rouge et
or ce rejet s'explique évidemment par
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de
l'émotion et c'est ce sur quoi je
voudrais qu'on travaille ensemble ce
soir
donc au lieu de vous résumer mon livre
je vous propose de faire ensemble de la
recherche en philosophie
vous allez voir comment ça marche donc
c'est comme dans les avions vous vous
mettez pas à crier on va tous mourir à
la première turbulences et bien là aussi
un moment vous comprenez pas ne vous
mettez pas à penser j'y comprends rien
parce que il ya un moment où vous allez
raccrocher vous allez voir ça passe ça
va pas faire mal
lorsqu'on ressent une émotion on est
évidemment concentrer sur son intimité
on est convaincu que cette émotion elle
vient du coeur que l on la ressent dans
son for intérieur et donc qu'elle est à
soi et bien sûr si nous nous mettons
nous à réfléchir philosophiquement sur
cette émotion
on va bien sûr lui restituer ce qu'on
appelle généralement un contexte
le contexte est constitué de choses qui
se trouvent autour de la personne dans
un contexte il ya plusieurs éléments qui
en réalité sont fixes prédéterminé il
préexiste à la situation qui va créer
l'émotion et pourtant ils y participent
ce sont des éléments objectifs
contrairement à l'émotion qui évidemment
est subjective et enfin les éléments du
contexte sont divers facteurs que l'on
peut étudier d'une manière objective
c'est à dire qu'ils sont de l'ordre du
connaissable ce que je voudrais faire
avec vous ce soir c'est justement
substituer à cette dualité entre une
émotion qui est fondamentalement la
mienne qui est dans mon dans mon for
intérieur qui est quelque chose de
subjectif et l'idée du contexte qui lui
est objectif et qui se trouve à
l'extérieur
un autre dispositif un autre système
c'est ce que j'appelle une configuration
pour commencer dans une configuration on
prend d'abord en compte une perspective
comme vous le voyez au lieu de présenter
dans l'absolu mais deux petits
personnages à l'intérieur du contexte
à présent nous avons pris la perspective
d'un des acteurs de l'événement et dans
cette configuration ce qui apparaît
n'est évidemment qu'une partie de ce que
nous appelions le contexte c'est très
important ça signifie que une
configuration c'est d'abord une
perspective d'éléments ce qui
complexifie un peu le phénomène c'est
que bien sûr dans cette configuration
tous les éléments ne sont pas à
l'extérieur par exemple lorsque je me
mets en colère contre mon colocataire
il ya tout un tas de petits mois qui
existent en moi et qui entrent en lutte
les uns avec les autres
c'est un peu l'image du
du diable et de et de l'ange qu'on
connaît bien
et en réalité il y en a beaucoup plus
parce qu'ils sont fait notamment de
nos expériences passées mais aussi de
tout un tas de personnalités
le petit garçon en moi la petite fille
en vous qui vont réagir en fait à des
stimuli extérieurs et qui vont prendre
le pas sur ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
de cette manière vous voyez que la
configuration ce ne sont plus seulement
des éléments objectifs situés à
l'extérieur ce sont aussi des éléments
considérés comme subjectif mais qui
petit à petit déconstruisent la notion
même de sujets puisque vous ne contrôlez
pas en fait ces éléments qui prennent
possession de vous et puis enfin il faut
admettre qu'une configuration se
transforme directement selon qu'on
change son point de vue bien sûr si dans
une situation qui vous paraît sans issue
cet affrontement permanente vous avec
votre chef s'est plainte perpétuelle de
votre ex
pour ce qui concerne la garde des
enfants ou même sept personnes qui vous
qui vous agressent tous les matins dès
que vous rentrez dans le bureau toutes
ces situations là en fait sont
déterminés comme je le dis par des
perspectives qui si elle changeait
changerait entièrement la configuration
dans mon petit schéma j'ai imaginé une
porte dérobée se trouvait un sur le côté
qui était jusqu'à alors caché et en
tenant compte d'une nouvelle perspective
en fait toute la configuration change
c'est très important parce que ça
signifie que au lieu de vous focaliser
d'une part sur votre émotion
d'autre part sur la personne qui est en
face de vous et qu'il a su site qui fait
que vous vous enflammez qui fait que
vous entrez dans la colère ou dans la
tristesse ou dans le désespoir
les émotions sont très nombreuses et
bien vous allez vous concentrez
justement sur ces éléments qui sont
extrêmement complexes et qui en réalité
sont en interaction
la grande difficulté c'est que le
complexe ça ne s'arrête jamais et on
peut toujours complexifier encore en
l'occurrence ce que je vous ai présenté
comme étant une configuration simple et
compliqué parce que j'appelle des
matrices des matrices sont les codes qui
permettent de mettre en forme la
configuration à partir de nos
représentations
en effet nous parlons une certaine
langue dans laquelle par exemple le mot
qu'on a eu un spectre du zaz extrêmement
large
lorsqu on est on est en train de
traduire le livre dont je parle et c'est
très difficile de restituer dans
d'autres langues
ce que nous signifions nous français
lorsque nous disons quelconque alcon un
mot qu'en plus on peut utiliser pour soi
même en disant que je suis con ou en en
se disant qu'on est toujours le con de
quelqu'un donc la langue est l'un des
éléments mais il ya aussi les
expériences passées j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure
et puis il ya même les expériences
passées dont vous avez entendu parler il
ya les livres que vous l'avez que vous
avez lu les films que vous avez vu tout
cela en fait qui façonnent votre
sensibilité de telle sorte qu'en réalité
lorsque vous êtes confronté un événement
ce sont ces matrices là qui vont le
mettre en forme
donc en fait ce sont des configurations
passé pour la plupart qui nous hante
exactement comme des fantômes dont nous
ne savons plus exactement d'où ils
viennent mais qui font partie de notre
monde sans que nous nous en apercevions
et puis il ya encore un troisième
élément que je voudrais prendre en
compte que j'appelle les scénarios les
scénarios décrivent des fictions de
configuration c'est à dire ce que vous
vous représenter mentalement parfois
très rapidement comme des possibles en
l'occurrence j'ai parfois pensé au
meurtre dans le cas de ma colocation je
vous rassure
par chance j'avais des scénarios
alternatifs
donc j'ai pris mes jambes à mon cou et
j'ai changé de maison c'était été
relativement facile à résoudre comme
problème il ya des problèmes qui sont
plus compliquées justement quand les
comptes font partie de votre famille et
que vous voulez retrouver
systématiquement à noël dieu merci
moi et mes parents sont pas dans la
salle je pensais pas que je le jure
mais comme vous voyez il n'est pas
toujours possible de trouver une issue
simple et pour trouver ces issues qui
n'apparaissent pas à l'oeil nu
il est absolument indispensable de
considérer des scénarios qui ne tiennent
pas exactement compte de ce qu'on
appelle le possible mais qui au
contraire assume le caractère fictionnel
ou plus exactement fictionné du désir le
désir fabrique de la fiction et c'est
avec ces fictions qu'en réalité nos
rêves deviennent réalité est que je suis
enfin libéré de ma muse la plus
improbable qui m'a inspiré ce travail
sur les cons vous comprenez à partir de
maintenant que ce qu'on considérait au
début de cette présentation comme une
émotion 6 ou creux dans de notre
intimité au fond de notre coeur
en réalité circule d'une manière
extrêmement complexes entre trois
ensembles qui ne sont ni subjectif ni
objectifs ce que j'appelais les matrices
qui sont en fait des configurations
passé ce qu'on considère comme étant la
configuration actuelle
mais comme je voulais dit il ya beaucoup
du passé qui fabrique notre présent et
puis enfin des configurations qu'on se
représente comme des futurs possibles et
qu'ils sont en réalité des fictions qui
met en forme notre désir voilà
ce que c'est que l'émotion c'est
l'énergie qui circulent entre ces trois
ensembles pour le dire d'une manière à
la fois plus simple et plus compliqué on
pourrait dire que l'émotion c'est une
qualité de présence interactionnelle
interactionnelle parce que comme vous
l'avez vu ça circule ce sont des
interactions entre des éléments qui vont
très vite c'est très complexe
c'est de la présence puisque en réalité
tout se met à exister au même moment ce
qu'on appelle un événement c'est ce qui
se passe est donc cet événement n'est
pas seulement subjectif puisqu'au
contraire il est extraordinairement
complexe
ça signifie que lorsque vous allez
vouloir contrôler vos émotions vous
essayer de toucher à quelque chose qui
n'est pas complètement à vous sur lequel
vous n'avez pas complètement la main et
vous croyez que la volonté va suffire
vous vous trompez
parce que ceux qui fabriquent l'émotion
c'est justement la circulation entre
trois ensembles complexes
vous n'avez pas le choix de ressentir
vos émotions
en revanche ce que vous pouvez faire
c'est orienter vos émotions
de telle sorte à ce qu'elle puisse
justement transformer les configurations
c'est cela en fait qui est la seule
porte de sortie d'une émotion quelconque
et c'est cela qui m'autorise à vous
donner à présent trois conseils contre
les cons ceux qui vous blesse ce qui
vous irrite ce qui vous met en danger
inutilement ce qui vous accable le
premier s'est raffiné vos matrix c'est à
dire lisez des livres des romans des
livres de philosophie des livres en fête
qui vont qui vont faire en sorte que les
cadres à partir desquels vous concevez
votre présent soit plus sophistiqué le
plus sophistiqué possible le deuxième
conseil étendez vos configurations
lorsque vous vous trouvez en proie à une
émotion une émotion qui vous submerge
fait en sorte que le monde auquel vous
vous référez le nombre d'éléments que
vous prenez en compte le nombre
d'interactions que vous considérez soit
le plus grand possible compliqué
complexifier les situations de référence
et puis enfin je vous demanderai de
multiplier les scénarios puisque en
réalité pour faire en sorte que le désir
trouve sa voie il est indispensable de
fictionné c'est-à-dire d'envisager
encore une fois des futurs
si vous le faites alors nécessairement
quelle que soit la tournure que prennent
les événements l'une de ses tournures
correspondra au scénario que vous aviez
imaginé voilà à présent vous savez
presque tout et j'ai envie de vous dire
bonne chance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]